pop quiz done which of these faces is
more trustworthy but would you vote for
would you kill one person to save
thousands oh you may also ask yourself
well how did I get here how did I become
a tiny doll all of these questions and
more are part of a new exhibit by former
Talking Heads frontman David Byrne and
his collaborator Mulligan Carr it's
called neuro Society an organization
that we got in touch with called the
Institute kind of a network of a lot of
neuroscience labs we said we would like
to make their work known and experienced
by a wider public it's a mix of theater
real neuroscience research and some
cutting-edge technology when a lot of
people see VR goggles they immediately
think gaming but right now I'm in a room
in Menlo Park where the point of these
goggles isn't to transport me to some
virtual gaming arena it's to trick my
brain into thinking I'm 12 inches tall
this is going to get a little weird but
it's very cool so stick with us back in
2011 some researchers in Sweden used VR
to transplant their test subjects into
the bodies of dolls it was a really cool
experiment it got a ton of press people
called it the body size effect and if
you read about it at the time I bet you
wish you could have experienced it for
yourself and now you can that's what
this room is for that's what these
goggles are for and it's what that
creepy doll is for this is Brita and for
a little while I was her or she was me
it was kind of weird sometimes but also
really cool and kind of terrifying
becoming Brita is one of a half-dozen
brain bending experiments you can
experience for yourself at the show we
discovered that a lot of science comes
out of improvisation try this know try
this which is kind of what happens in
the arts as well burn and Gong car gave
wired an early look people go through in
groups led by guides but in each case
it's a science experiment that's been
recreated in this classroom visitors
recreate a Princeton scientists
experiment about snap judgment and how
trustworthy we find facial expressions
by voting for one of two real candidates
we reconstruct his experiment which is
really around how when people are forced
to make very quick decisions and
implicit decisions on candidates how
they decide based upon a very set
pattern and you overlay his results
based upon three second decisions versus
the actual election results the overlap
is fairly astonishing so just a
two-thirds up to 70% overlap in many
cases had enough politics and it's off
to the neuro Society game show the games
begin the design of the different rooms
was to some extent sometimes is a
stretch but to some extent was
determined by what they experiment what
the scientific work is if you have an
injury let's say if you lost your finger
would you still be you you will have
three seconds to answer yes or no
starting now the kind of decision making
especially from a group as far as moral
decisions or social decisions I thought
there I've seen that in game shows on TV
so whether you're into game show
sociology or just looking to have an
out-of-body or in doll body experience
the show runs through the end of March
coming in and being embodied in the but
a body of a little Swedish doll as well
you need need a clinical place to do
that so that there's no slipshod
mistakes and something could go very
very wrong